[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mario striker's battle league
prepare for strike a five-on-five sport
like soccer that's way heavy on offense
aim for goals by dribbling and passing
to teammates as well as by using tackles
items
and crushing special shots
the main rule in this sport is to rule
the field
try to score more goals than your
opponents
there are two things to keep in mind
that'll help you with your strategies
first the gear you equip it changes not
only your appearance but also your stats
like speed strength and pass accuracy
customize as you see fit
second
the hyper strike
to activate this shot grab an orb when
it appears on the field
and charge it while your opponents are
distracted
hit the net and you'll score not one but
two goals
up to eight players four players on each
team can compete against each other on
one nintendo switch system
in addition to individual matches
online play will have an online club
mode
join an in-game club and compete for
placement in the rankings
up to 20 players can join a club so
create your own and invite friends and
family to play alongside you or join an
existing one owned by other players
try to become the world's tough club
with items
tackles and hyper strikes
anything goes on this field
mario strikers battle league launches on
nintendo switch june 10th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop